meantime Let's uh bring in the health
secretary Steve Barclay good morning
it's good to see you as always thanks
for joining us on the program just
hearing what's happening there at the
Parry Garden or airport
um airport train station How concerned
are you about what we've heard about
what's happening at Heathrow Airport as
well we heard that there was um some
material that anti-terror police were
involved in and and I don't know what's
happening well I'm obviously learning
about this uh this morning and clearly
there's an investigation underway and
it's right that that looks at all the
issues and I'm sure it will report in
due course okay
um obviously very alarming for a lot of
people this morning but as you say
information's still coming in on that
what we can say in other matters
particularly as far as your brief is
concerned 50 000 more deaths in the NHS
over the past 12 months either well all
countries are looking across Europe
facing a similar issue is what is the
consequence of the pandemic clearly
during the pandemic there will be some
patients who delayed treatment
particularly we're seeing some of that
play through in pressure on
cardiovascular conditions there'll be
some directly linked some of those
deaths to covid itself some of it may be
indirectly where for example someone's
waiting for treatment we've got a
challenge in terms of people waiting for
operations that were working very
actively to clear so it's extremely
complicated as to what the driver of
those excess deaths are that's something
we're looking closely I'm talking to the
chief medical officer how alarmed are
you by those numbers well it's clearly
concerning but it's not something that's
just affecting us in England it's
something I know but all countries 50
000 people dead who wouldn't have been
otherwise you must be alarmed well it's
concerning that the VAR those but
clearly we knew at the time of the
pandemic that in order to prevent
further dress deaths as a result of
covid we needed to take a whole range of
very severe actions and and those had an
impact those had an impact in uh further
weights for operations they had an
impact in patients who didn't get
treatment at the time now we've got a
recovery plan in place we cleared the
longest weights the two-year weights
over the summer we're now focused on the
78-week weights and working on those to
get those down so we've invested more in
the Autumn statement an extra 6.6
billion yeah
but obviously the ambulance workers on
strike again today your colleague Grant
chaps saying striking paramedics are
risking lives do you agree with them
well if there's delays to ambulances
obviously it is concerning in terms of
our ability to that that care but we've
been working with the unions
constructively on what cover they will
put in place I'm very pleased that we
have
well it's clearly a concern in terms of
the impact that it has on patient safety
but we're working constructively with
the unions in terms of particularly for
life-threatening calls those most urgent
999 cores and what we're saying to the
public is where there is a genuine
life-threatening urgency the most
important category one calls are being
covered but clearly there'll be wider
pressure on the ambulance system today
so we're saying to people to be mindful
of that but if they do have a
life-threatening condition the most
urging cataging one calls are covered
today okay GMB Union had them on the
show just a few moments ago while you
were speaking to some of our colleagues
at other outlets and they're saying
these talks that you've been holding
have been pointless no I think even the
if I take Sarah Gordon who's the the
head of the NHS staff Council she said
after the talks that I had with them on
Monday that there had been progress I'm
seeing the doctor's union today to have
discussions with them we believe Kay
that the right approach is to have the
independent pay-per-view body look at
these issues in terms of what it is not
independent but it is independent and
even the opposition of the independent
pay with your body is describing is
chosen by the Prime Minister and
ministers to choose other people within
that pay review body so it might happen
well even the the opposition recognized
so labor has said that they themselves
support an independent pay review body
process that's something that
governments of different colors have had
successively for many years it's able to
look at these issues in the round but
we're working constructively with the
unions to see what further things that
we can do that's why we had the
discussions on Monday because we want to
get the evidence for this coming years
pay review body to reflect the pressures
that the system are under and that's
what we were discussing with them on
Monday I told you what the GMB have said
this morning the head of the national
lead for unite saying that you only
wanted to talk about productivity do you
think that NHS workers should work
harder to get Fair rides well
productivity is not about working harder
it's about getting the system as a whole
to work better it's about for example
the investment in technology it's about
enabling people who have had training to
be focused on what that training is best
for rather than for example many of
their frustrations with some of the
administrations some of the bureaucracy
some of the things in the system that
are not working as they should and
actually that's common ground with the
trade unions the trend unions say to me
often they are frustrated on behalf of
their members with some of the
inefficiencies in the system so it's
right that we look at where can we work
smarter better in a more effective way
what is the right investment in
technology what is the cost of agents at
the moment and count we look at how we
bring that down so there are areas we
can work together with the trade unions
on that and you use that to make any pay
review body settlement more affordable
in April General Secretary of the TUC
Paul Novak saying that the anti-strike
laws that you want to bring in are
undemocratic what will happen if workers
just ignore these laws and strike anyway
well they say it's undemocratic but lots
of other European countries have them
and I don't hear them saying that France
is undemocratic if people don't if
people ignore break the law basically
and go on strike well firstly what I'm
saying is is lots of other European
countries have these so when people say
it's undemocratic it is something that
they have in France they have in Italy
they have in Spain and I don't think
anyone's seriously suggesting these
countries are undemocratic but what
we're saying is if we look at the way
the ocn have approached National
arrangements for the strikes they've
acted very responsibly to to be fair to
them in terms of having a national
arrangement in place
of prime minister Barclay as you know
what will you do if workers break the
law and go on strike well this is about
having a safety net there as they do in
other European countries to ensure that
there are minimum safety levels minimum
service levels in place we will debate
this in Parliament in terms of how this
will apply we're just looking at
ambulances in the first instance in
terms of health
it's about it's not going to prosecute
this it's about their behavior much more
of the unions it's about the behavior of
the unions more than uh individual
members so for example there's a marked
difference between what we've seen with
the RCN who have had National
Arrangements in place to guarantee
safety and what we've seen with the
ambulance strikes where even up to
midnight last night I was getting calls
in terms of what Arrangements would be
in place in terms of the local cover the
minimum safety levels that will be in
place because the ambulance unions have
refused to do that at a national level
and my concern is patient safety that is
what my question is how would you
implement this law if people go on
strike and it's against the law breaking
the law what do you do well as they do
in other European countries it's about
having a safety net that applies to the
behavior of the trade unions
we're going to debate this it'll
probably take about six months in
Parliament for the legislation to pass
so we were screwed this will be
scrutinized we will debate this in
Parliament but it's about saying we want
to be in a position to have national
minimum safety levels in place just as
they do in France in Spain in Italy what
do you accept that the NHS is on its
knees on your watch well it's under huge
pressure but that's not just in England
if you look at what the first Minister
said on Monday Scottish hospitals are
near completely full if you look at
Wales more than 50 000 people waiting
more than two years for an operation if
you look at my counterpart in France he
said that
I mean in terms of people in England who
you represent and they feel that the NHS
is on its knees do you acknowledge that
the NHS is under huge pressure and I
acknowledge that uh in the House of
Commons more than Monday well more so
because of the pandemic because of the
combination of the delayed discharge the
people in hospital who are fit to leave
and have been delayed we recognize that
with the extra funding we're putting in
place in the Autumn statement on top of
that you've got around 9 000 people over
9000 people in hospital recovered and
then we had this massive surge as they
did across Europe with flu cases over
Christmas a seven-fold increase uh
compared to November there's a hundred
times more patients in hospital with flu
this year compared yes I've had both and
if I could make One Plea to any members
we've extended the number of people that
can have access to the job and if
there's any of your viewers particularly
over 50 or in the cohorts that are at
risk who haven't had their vaccination
if it'll make a plea k for them are you
looking at me I'm saying anyone anyone
anyone who's not had their their job who
is is watching this uh if I could
urgency okay well when I get to 50 I
might do it thanks thanks very much it's
good to see you as always thanks very
much indeed thanks for joining us